i forgot to look up which episode or a
couple of episodes
we talked uh in some depth about robin
deangelo's white fragility
uh and i'm not prepared to do a complete
takedown of
ibram x kendi's how to be an anti-racist
just yet because i've only gotten
through
i don't know a third of it um but i want
to talk a little bit about
about this because this you know because
because the author of this book
is a black man unlike roman d'angelo
who's a white woman
um her book has begun to fall out of
favor
apparently in some of these die
diversity inclusion equity trainings
and his kendy's book is becoming more
popular and in fact he's
you know he's he is a rising star as he
has been for a while
he is on uh he's on the cover of this
month's the atlantic
uh with a um an article called the power
of american denial
and so i just have a couple of excerpts
not the usual excerpts i try to read
excerpts that are
enlightening in some ways and i do not
find
rea anything about what i have read of
his stuff enlightening but it's
important for us
for us all to know what is being said in
in part
because just like d'angelo has redefined
what racist
means uh and the the way that you will
hear
people saying to you well if you're a
white person you are inherently racist
that that comes mostly out of the
d'angelo playbook
well candy framed this like you're
racist
or you're anti-racist and that is a
complete solution set like that is his
framing
and uh just like black lives matter
uh and and other feel good
sound good phrases of course you want to
be anti-racist
obviously especially if the only other
option on the table
or allowed by your humanity is to be
racist of course you choose anti-racist
now he
unlike d'angelo gives us a choice right
like you can actually
aspire to be non-racist i'm not sure he
ever lets you there so that we still
have this sort of
original sin issue um but let me just
um use his words to define
what he means right so from from this
september
2020 issue of the atlantic he says this
is candy
from 1977 to 2018 the general social
survey asked whether black americans
quote
have worse jobs income and housing than
white people mainly due to
discrimination
kendi writes there are only two answers
to this question
the racist answer is no it presumes the
racist determine that racist
discrimination no longer exists
and that racial inequities are the
result of something being wrong with
black people
the anti-racist answer is yes it
presumes that nothing is wrong or right
inferior or superior about any racial
group so the explanation for racial
disparities must be discrimination
in 2008 he continues as obama was headed
for the white house
only 34.5 of respondents answered yes
a number i will call the anti-racist
rate
this was the second lowest anti-racist
rate of the 41-year polling period the
rate rose to 37.7
in 2010 perhaps because the emergence of
the tea party forced a reckoning for
some white americans
but it fell back down to 34.9 in 2012
and 34.6
in 2014. so
he has defined um
just to i have more quotes here but
um what he has done here is said
that um once again the actual question
being asked for the general social
survey is
do black americans have worse jobs
incoming housing than white people
mainly due to discrimination
there are only two answers to this
question now of course that question
is itself a whole bunch of questions and
you might legitimately say well i don't
i can't answer that question
that question is too many questions
already right
but kendy puts that aside he says no
actually
either yes um it's mainly do
discrimination in which ding ding ding
you win you're an anti-racist or at
least you're aspiring to be
or no i think that some
other explanation is also in play here
no you lose you're a racist these are
the only two possible answers
that that he will allow for so i would
point out also that this while
well candy as far as i know isn't uh
involved in the
sex isn't binary part of the uh
intersectional movement it's
all the same group and um
guess what they're wrong on both fronts
like sex is a binary like male and
female are real and that's what we have
and have for
500 million years um but disparities and
outcomes between racial groups
that's not a binary disparities and
outcomes between racial groups
undoubtedly has a strong explanatory
variable in historic racism and
some explanatory variable in current
racism but the idea that it is the only
thing that you are allowed to consider
else you have demonstrated that you are
racist is
not a legitimate rhetorical tactic but i
will say this for candy he is an
excellent
uh what would it be rhetorician
rhetoric guy um i'm not sure he's he's
very smart he's great with language he's
uh i'm sure he could write and talk
circles around d'angelo uh who's much
simpler to to get rid of
um so just to point out a few more of
his definitions
um from his from the book from how to be
an anti-racist
um there are three more places where he
sort of defines his new coding of racist
versus anti-racist
one if racial discrimination is defined
as treating considering or making a
distinction in favor or against an
individual based on that person's race
then racial discrimination is not
inherently racist
the defining question is whether the
discrimination is creating equity
or inequity if discrimination is
creating inequity
then it is racist he then goes on to say
if discrimination is creating equity
which is to say equal outcomes that's
what equity means equal outcomes
then it is anti-racist so discrimination
that creates equal outcomes is
anti-racist
this is why you should and could and
absolutely
must really strive to be not anti-racist
certainly not racist but not anti-racist
either because
that's ridiculous two
from page 20 of his book there is no
such thing as a not racist idea
only racist ideas and anti-racist ideas
so what is a racist idea a racist idea
is any idea that suggests that one
racial group
is inferior or superior to another
racial group in
any way three from pages
even like marathon running well that's
we're getting there oh okay
uh page 64. to be anti-racist is to view
national and transnational ethnic groups
as equal in all their differences
to be anti-racist is to view the
inequities between all racialized ethnic
groups as a problem of
policy so
i thought we might discuss a few
examples of people of european descent
being worse
or more susceptible to things and using
candy's
examples then we're clearly engaging in
racism when we talk about europeans not
being
as good at something the obvious example
as you just pointed out brett is
um marathon running so
so zach if you want to show this briefly
this is a 2012 article from the atlantic
the very same
once great monthly publication that is
now
putting this kind of ridiculous thinking
on its cover
why kenyans make such great runners a
story of genes and cultures
it's quite a good article um from it
i'm not sure if i can find zach if you
want to give me my screen back um i'm
going to read
a a
excerpt from this article which finds
which which doesn't find this article is
not a piece of original research which
uh points to the now well-known finding
that kenyans are better it's not just
even africans per se but kenyans
are better at long-distance running and
that canyons and ethiopians
is the uh yeah you know it's actually
it's it's not as clear
apparently for ethiopians the uh the
finding uh the statistical
finding for kenyans is it's much more
clear and in fact it seems to be a
particular
tribe within kenya okay so here we have
an extended quotation from this 2012
atlantic article it turns out that
kenyan's success may be innate
two separate european lead studies in a
small region in western kenya which
produces most of the race winners
found that young men there could with
only a few months training
reliably outperform some of the west's
best professional runners
in other words they appear to have a
physical advantage that is common to
their community
making it probably genetic the studies
found significant differences in body
mass index and bone structure between
the western pros and the kenyan amateurs
who had bested them
the studied kenyans had less mass for
their height longer legs shorter torsos
and more slender limbs one of the
researchers described the kenyan
physical differences as bird-like noting
that these traits would make them more
efficient runners especially over long
distances
surprisingly the 2012 atlantic article
continues
western popular writing about kenyan's
running success seems to focus less on
these genetic distinctions and more on
cultural differences
for years the cultural argument has been
that kenyans became become great runners
because they often run several miles to
and from school every day
but about a decade ago someone started
asking actual kenyans if this was true
and it turned out to be merely a
byproduct of western imaginations
14 of 20 surveyed kenyan race winners
said they'd walked or ridden the bus to
school
like normal children do another cultural
argument says they run barefoot which
develops good habits but if this were
true then surely the far more populated
countries of south asia
where living without shoes is also
common would dominate over kenyans
another ascribes it to the quote simple
food of kenya but this again is true of
many other parts of the world and
kenya's not so great health records
suggest the country has not discovered
the secret to great nutrition
and there is a cringe-inducing theory
still prevalent that kenyan's history as
herders mean they get practice running
as they chase their sheep across the
countryside
so i mean i think there's a lot to be
said here
but one of them is one of the things to
be said here is that all of those
cultural hypotheses that are apparently
preferred in the western press
are themselves pretty freaking racist
right they like they smack of this old
school cultural anthropology
which was like okay we're going to come
in on our you know our
white anthropologists on our white
horses not that anthropologists tend to
ride in our horses but
um and you know and save you from
yourselves and you know point out
how um your your pre-industrial ways
actually make you better at some things
but you know unspoken wink-wink probably
not so good at some other things so you
know that's
actually some so anthropological racism
built into those those stories about you
know the culture
being the reason that these kenyans with
let's see
less mass for their height longer legs
shorter torsos more slender limbs
are doing better uh at breaking marathon
records
uh than uh people from other parts of
the world
yeah i'm not sure i find i mean i find
those
anthropological explanations tone deaf
and ignorant
i'm not sure i find them racist but
[Music]
we also have to be a bit careful here
because the physiological
and morphological differences between
populations are
large and they account for things in the
real world that have nothing to do with
discrimination
right in fact discrimination has denied
advantages
to people who would have been superior
at sports until they finally broke into
them so we've seen that
in boxing we've seen that in uh
baseball we've seen it in tennis um
and you know the the fact is those
differences are real
they are based in trade-offs right
so it is the fact that different
habitats select for different things
that result in different populations
playing different sports better than
others
that does not inherently have any
implication
whatsoever for cognition could there be
differences in cognition there could be
but they are much
less likely and so what i'm troubled by
is that the examples that we have to
resort to in order to prove that the
logic that candy is deploying here is
faulty
because we can see very clear examples
in which physiology and morphology
explain something that has nothing to do
with racism and does generate the
pattern proving there's a third category
of explanation
right but that suggests that what we're
saying is
wink wink that same third category is
what explains differences in success
between populations
when in fact that probably does have a
lot to do with historical racism
which doesn't say anything about modern
racism and so i
again i'm feeling just a bit hopeless
because the real problem with his
argument
is that almost nobody has
the patience and the knowledge set
to be able to go through it and see
exactly where the little logical errors
are that have these gigantic effects on
the conclusion
right so you have to be able to spot
those things basically at some level i
feel like
all of us need to spend a week
going through these arguments and
figuring out which part of them is true
which part of part of them is faulty
what implication it has for the
the conclusion because otherwise we're
going to tear civilization apart over
the fact that
most people do not know how to take
apart candy's argument
right um so i mean we've got
um we've got kenyans being better at
marathon running
at the at the disease level so you know
we have said
race is a a bastardization a
messy imprecise at best inaccurate
very very often if not always
representation of a real
genetic and evolutionary concept called
population right
and we can see with regard to disease
also that there are distinctions between
between groups tay sachs is is
concentrated among ashkenazi jews
right sickle being homozygous for sickle
cell anemia
uh is concentrated among african
americans within
north america right so those are
observations that are borne out
by by the testing that is accurate
and in candy's rubric
pointing out that those accus those
observations are
true is itself a racist act
so um to pretend that they're not true
would be the only way forward to be
anti-racist
which is obviously not a tenable
position to stand on right
this is like the foundation is is really
unstable
um in in
do you have something to say yeah i i
just wanted to point out that
in part this argument is built it's not
about
logic it's about power and you can tell
it's about power because it's so
categorical
right and so the the right challenge to
it is something like
let's imagine a situation in which
um some
group of violent
white identitarians are kidnapping
black people and killing them right
where the explanation
is 100 racism
it is still not correct in that case to
say the only possibility
is this in other words the idea that a
logical argument
required as you point out it requires a
complete solution set
of answers that could be right even when
there's
no currency to one of those answers it
still exists as a formal possibility
and any argument that says the formal
possibilities that aren't an important
player in the story
are no longer formal possibilities is
about ruling them out for reasons that
aren't logical they're about power
right and so you know and the fact that
he
is defining and this is now spreading
throughout all of these diversity
inclusion and equity
workplace trainings that many of you
have had to have been forced to sit
through
that he is defining um the solution set
as racist versus anti-racist and
anti-racist
is in he's not ambiguous about this
it requires equal outcomes
for any group that you could define any
group
which also means you can just create
your own group and say ah
i'm underrepresented because i just
created myself and you know i don't find
myself over there
so you'd better hire me because i need
to be represented there
yeah it's a loophole i can invent a new
gender my gender is one that
oscillates between male and female i
spend two thirds of my
time male one third of my time female
and i just
reverberate back and i i have bad news
for you oh i don't think that's a new
gender
oh i think it's been done to say yeah
um all right it's a little hard to know
how to come back from that but
well you could you could publicly for
the first time here announce what your
actual
pronouns are the pronouns i use
for myself and why are me and i yeah but
with regard to the part of orca that you
identify as oh i definitely identify as
a part of worker
and uh why is that again
is that because it it uh it gives voice
to
uh my black and white sides i don't know
something yeah yeah yeah you're adult
and you're juvenile you're yeah
and the young enough of this playing
with these very dangerous concepts
um but yeah yeah well actually so um a
few more things from the book
and then um i have something that a
teacher a public school teacher who had
to sit through some faculty and staff
training
in the last couple of weeks uh sent me
uh in which supposedly
um you know which is built on all of
this d'angelo candy style
um thinking but just you know other
things that he says in this book
um he explains he takes some time to
explain why pre-modern islamic slave
traders were not pursuing racist
policies
um all right it's gonna take me a second
well yeah it would it
it should take you a long second
actually i'll just have
a very long second i did not see this
coming no
no no no uh he says uh
pre-modern islamic slave traders like
their christian counterparts in
pre-modern italy
were not pursuing racist policies they
were enslaving what we now consider to
be africans arabs and europeans alike
at the dawn of the modern world the
portuguese began to exclusively trade
african bodies
prince henry sailors made history when
they navigated past the feared
black hole of cape bohador off western
sahara and brought enslaved africans
back to portugal
so i'm sure that he would not say that
he was being an apologist for slavers
who weren't
um being slavers in a racial way but it
certainly seems like that's what he's
doing
he's he's focusing on racialized
by which he actually means just you know
geographically focused
um and you know elsewhere in the book he
makes it clear that actually geography
isn't race that race is not real and so
you know he's he's going back and forth
between all sorts of arguments and being
inconsistent
um but uh he makes a point
of sort of excluding the pre-modern
islamic slave traders from
his ire because they were equal
opportunity slavers or something
so that's that's that's one thing
and so you know he obviously points out
the flaw in his own argument
which is that even in the case of a
completely
racialized slave trade you don't know
that it would have been if the geography
had been distributed differently yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah so a couple pages later he
talks about um linnaeus
who as we know is biologists and as many
people who remember their high school
biology will remember
um was the guy who first tried to start
categorizing
um life on earth with these you know
binomial binomial species names like
homo sapiens
domesticus or case familiaris familiaris
that's humans domestic cats domestic
dogs um
and illinois was as as we know actually
you know
very confused at one level he he called
it
he identified as scala nachuri in which
you were ascending to become better and
better and better and humans were
were the top and candy focuses on
linnaeus
did not restrict his hierarchical um
strange and and misguided thinking to uh
species outs to to things outside of
humans but he also had a hierarchy of
racism
themselves which is of course racist and
also not at all surprising and totally
in keeping with the rest of what he did
um so i don't know if candy ignores the
fact that linnaeus was
consistently hierarchical and not a good
thinker in this regard
because he doesn't know what happened or
because it serves his argument
um that you know the history of western
science is racist well
in this case it's a you know it's a
classic example because
linnaeus is pre-darwinian and so
the fact is linnaeus didn't know that he
was
interfacing with a world in which all of
these
different coexisting species were
actually
coexisting from a shared ancestry and
therefore the scala nature doesn't make
any sense
so uh you know the point is okay
if you analyze linnaeus in the context
in which linnaeus existed
you get one answer if you decide to go
after linnaeus on the basis that we now
know enough to understand why he was
being
um foolish then okay what have you
accomplished really it's retrospective
bigoteering
it's a retrospective bigoteering yep
exactly
okay one more uh one more point from
from candy before
uh we move on to our final thing and
then it looks like we're over an hour at
this point
um he uh
ah he points out let me actually find
the quote in here
this is page 50 in this book um
at the 1988 american heart associate
association conference he writes a black
hypertension researcher said african
americans had higher hypertension rates
because only those are
able to retain high levels of salt
survived consuming the salt water of the
atlantic ocean during the middle passage
i've bounced this off a number of
colleagues and it seems certainly
plausible clarence grimm told swooning
reporters
plausibility became proof and the
slavery hypertension thesis received the
red carpet
in the cardiovascular community in the
1990s graham did not arrive at the
thesis in his research lab
it came to him as he read roots by alex
haley who needed scientific proof when a
biological
racial distinction can be imagined by
reading fiction by reading the bible
so there is so much wrong with that
passage right
um one candy appears to um
basically be taking the possibility
of selection on human beings off the
table
as ever being an explanation that we are
allowed to speak about
so it's fundamentally a religious
position that he is that he is
advocating for
um he clearly misunderstands what
science is because the idea
that a researcher got a hypothesis from
a source that wasn't in his lab while
wearing his white lab coat and
handling glassware is of course where
that's that's what that's what
hypothesis
is ideas are creativity they do come
from serendipity they do
come from people actually exposing
themselves to ideas far and wide and
being in places that they haven't been
before and not foreseeing what it was
that they would find
hypotheses are then tested through
careful
rigorous observation or experimentation
depending on exactly what your test
is and what the hypothesis was and i
don't know if this has actually been
tested this hypothesis
but it is an evolutionary hypothesis
that is um that is at least plausible at
the level of
did the middle passage have selective
effects on the populations that were
so grotesquely ripped from their
homelands and enslaved
yes because we know large numbers of
people died
during the middle passage it would be
frankly extraordinary if there had been
no selection
then is that honorable is it good is
that wonderful in any way no
no one is making that claim but kendi is
taking off the table the possibility of
an evolutionary explanation
for any differences um under any
circumstances it appears which means
we're just you know he has stripped us
of all of our tools
right so again the stripping
of the tools is clearly the point
and somehow you either get this or you
don't
you either take all of these arguments
about
arithmetic not you know being a
white thing and shut down a stem because
of its
inherent racism or whatever you either
understand that
all of this is about eliminating any
basis on which you could object to a
claim that justifies a transfer of
well-being
that's really the point transfer of
well-being is the is the objective
and that transfer of well-being is being
justified on the basis of things that
are
either not completely true or not at all
true and in order to prevent them from
being exposed as false you have to get
rid of all the bases on which you might
establish their true
their truth or falsity such as
logic such as science such as statistics
and that's what we're facing if these
things are not under attack
for no reason or out of some sort of
incoherence it's
absolutely a coherent plan about
transferring
well-being in the pursuit of something
that is ironically being called equity
which is
nothing like it and frankly the fact
that equity
well it is but unfortunately it is
because equity doesn't mean what we
think it means right right and this this
is another place where
are you well of course i'm anti-racist
of course i stand for black lives matter
of course i'm for equity
like no you should 100 be non-racist and
also
non-anti-racist you of course should
understand that black lives matter but
not hashtag
black lives matter unless you understood
everything that that movement is
actually standing for
and actually equity is not the same
thing as equality and the people who are
trying out equity as the goal know that
very very well
so what that what that means to them is
equality of
outcome but it doesn't even right that's
the claim
the most generous interpretation of what
they're saying is equality of
outcome but the point is even equality
of outcome
assumes some ability to measure when it
is equal
and when it isn't as stupid as it would
be to pursue equality of outcome
obliterating the standard by which you
might judge when it has been
reached means that this is just transfer
it all to me
now because equity will be reached when
i say it's reached and you know it'll be
reached
never they tell us that yeah right this
was frequently said at evergreen and
i've seen it seen
repeated many times since we left which
is this job will never be done
you